ciao a tutti e benvenuti su alberi oggi
faremo un video è di nuovo video su tre
con nicolas challenge se vi ricordate lo
abbiamo già fatto con la folla havers
questa volta però abbiamo nuovi colori
ne abbiamo tantissimi in più hanno la
specialità questi colori perché non sono
colori normali ma alcuni sono glitterati
e alcuni sono metallizzazione rocco sarà
un bellissimo è convenuto di vedere come
sia lo slime comunque i colori in più
non vedo l'ora di vedere che i colori ci
capiteranno e che colori diventerà un
fiato interessante ci abbiamo qualche
dubbio l'altro 6 purtroppo era nel kit e
non lo sono io ma purtroppo devo
prendere anche quello allora come
funziona la challenge come della terza
legge dovremmo fare gli occhi e pestare
tre colori
poi dovremo fare lo stress non
mischiando coi tre colori vince e essere
lo sligo più bello
potete votare vi metterò il sondaggio
qui e potrete votare siamo i toni
testing sareste ti diciamo servizio
vitale per ora mettetevi comodi questa
volta invece di banda di remo corno
questo organizza a fare freddo prendete
pronte caso abbiamo mille altre di b b
allora mettetevi cori e abbiamo subito
allora inizia institut ha il proprio
brand ha sì io nel frattempo li mischio
credere bellissimo ok
vai e questo bird
io non posso dire niente rappresenta
definitiva ok puoi guardare
che bello che abita recapitato il blu
metallizzato glossy via da cannes detto
al the blue apple ha preferito pronta ok
poi mischiati a telefisco in linea ma
aiuto sento quello no sento il bene che
mi chiama aiuto e quello che parte
l'affetto non ci credo solo che io non
vedo niente e ovviamente io non la
voglio il verde nobel è questo il centro
a como
al centro è questo vedi 23 23 anzi certo
della procura certamente e di successo
certo non c'entra
ti faccio i capelli verdi 9 non si possa
credere a me la sentivo proprio comunque
autori detto pure lo sento che c'è
ancora grande una affettivo per l'italia
allora questo è il verde per fortuna non
è un verde e verbalizzato bellissimo e
metallizzato che questo è un po glossy
però è sono messi non è che perde acqua
quasi perderò meta tipo non saprei
profit web shop troppo trio di piano da
secoli non rimanga avverte vabbè vanno
corretti in blu metallizzato blu bene
e questo un blu dai segni dove stanno
questi qua metallizzata e bellissimo
questo giallo ma che colora creerà il
blues amicizia all'uscita verde eccolo
qua è bellissimo ti immagini se invece a
te gilbert de mischiando il colore verde
rischio durante milano nesso starebbe è
piccolo team
è il colore del mio team per tim burke
hare essendo un acconto
[Musica]
io spero di perché hanno un colore
brillantinato perché ancora noi abbiamo
pescato e a me piace tanto il rosa media
soltanto andiamo allora o per cotto
celeste brillantinato cioè più blu che
non sarebbe cosa sia un ep 299 show nel
colore verde è l'ultimo colore che
perché hai qui adesso di oggi
concentrati tu che il colore voti clicca
su questo brulé 31 cena più l'altro
giallo brillanti nardò nel rosa non
c'entra niente con questi club che c'è
il bianco e nero il bianco del peperino
maio sono o bianco al giallo fucsia rosa
ma era l'unico che non volevano fiamme
tagli da tutti secondo me è bellissimo
questo colore e di che colore sia
secondo
per evitare provate a indovinare prima
che gli mischiamo celeste rosa e giallo
nero marrone
ora giochiamo scaricare i fischi fischi
si fa colore per mirca viola mercato in
rosa glitter e sul cambio più o meno
sono stato fuori tre che io pensi gaudio
sono però io ho il clip seria però mi
raccomando lasciato ben likes e questo
quindi recentissimi la rai
andremo a fare un'altra alle corse
centro i tre colori ha rispetto dobbiamo
iniziare in ordine poi del primo colore
che pescato anche io li ho ordinati su
amazon ma non penso che sia ci sia anche
la colla dentro in altri c'è scritto
acrilico quindi solo colore e non è
servito gel glitter gel quindi
aggiungiamo la colla trasparente perché
non penso che si attivino da soli anche
pronti ad aggiungere il nostro primo
colore è iniziai a mettere l'italia a
nicola consiglieri carinissimo chiediamo
un po di colore diventa con questo verde
però metallizzato
oddio anche se purtroppo solo con un
colore
ecco il mio verde è già diventato
totalmente verde pensavo non lo so
istituisse un po per un bello affetto da
vuoi dire il colore è metallizzato
vedete perché bellissima limeremo però
di calcolare diventa una cosa che metti
in giallo e forse un po troppo
futuristico dove questo non è bastato
gli altri diventa nero ora andiamo team
perde piante ruoli quindi il secondo
melorio prezzo era il mio era celeste
basta che si vede poco beh perché sennò
poi dopo diventa super iper colorato e
omessa la mostarda nello stile ma
vediamo che colore diventa
ho capito perché vive perché siamo
l'altro dai tanti non lo sapeva nessuno
[Musica]
pur non è sentito in verde il tuo
perdere verde acqua che bello è sfumato
nei guai per la vittima è più belli del
mio perde questo mi sembra che abbiano
consistenza diversa e forse questo si
attiva come mai
dai dai cambia colore cambia con forti
allora la cosa positiva è che è
diventato glitterato e aggiungo un
pochettino di più quindi ai riflessi
glitter celesti
che è sempre verde purtroppo però ai
riflessi con i glitter chelsea quindi
speriamo che con il rota poi cambierà
qualcosa
bene allora non senti evitare diventata
una pagina da padrone
[Musica]
ok ora il nostro terzo colore sempre
imprevedibile questo challenge che sei
mediche con il video dello stesso colore
adesso quindi il tuo diventa dato
tantissimo è arrivato a grigio domeniche
come la libertà marroncino mettiamo esco
un bel colore fastidio la magari si sta
rifiutando e del rosso si sta rifiutando
di fondersi goria mi sa che hai amato
ancora un po
che fortuna sapersi ambra grigia e un
galaxy sempre con quella gara non è il
glitter crisi o forse lunga
immaginate dai secondo me ma salvando un
po e non esagera numero è caduto perché
nulla
viola grigio violetto grigio si però
oggi è salvato dai almeno non è più
verde ben sappiamo bene sembra quasi
perlato e un viola parlato io che
pensavo di perdere non pensa che vince
lo vedremo però meno coloro no prende
molto colore non cambia molto colore
forse si è sparito un po come secondo te
verde acqua da allora le liste g un
cerette sinceramente e acqua se ne sta
verde paludoso portoso io bel paese che
sembra fango quando mai un fango
benissimo ho trovato del nuovo ok ora
possiamo procedere a tutt altro che di
quello che è successo così come possiamo
far vedere bene sentiamo istudiez mr
e potete votare da una dieta bellezza e
suoni smr allora io non vedo l'ora di
vedere l'ottimo perché poi cambia anche
quando una volta che sia attivato cambia
anche una volta che sono sparite tutte
le bolle torna a fare il male che io ho
preso il colore del mio team più o meno
perché celeste è il mio al mio grido di
campo tutti i consigli che mi date nei
commenti su come attivato lo
scrapbooking sono molto utili grazie
grazie sto migliorando grazie a voi ma
chi grande città e migliorando ma pure
scritto nei commenti che sono migliorato
e un
sono dei commenti di incoraggiamento
bello rispetto non mi sono dovuto 0
riavvio adesso come lo fai questo pochi
in grado qua il mio sly vedete un po che
bella pulita che lo sta guardando bene
allora è diventato un celeste per
fortuna ea i glitter azzurri e rosa
sentiamo un po i suoni allora guardate
un po il colore che bello è il glitter
non so se riuscite a vederli e super
estendibile scrittore
[Musica]
quindi praticamente alla fine è 1 slime
trasparente con glitter
ovviamente ora non è molto trasparente
perché a tutte le bolle ed è leggermente
metallizzato giusto perché c'era il
verde metallizzato ma non tanto in mezzo
e vitale che ha usato tre colori
metallizzati vediamo dove diventando
alain di lì che ti sto preparando la
cosiddetta rotta in massa questo dato
che stanno aspettando
guardate ad airone male come twirl e
molto metallizzata la fine sito viola si
è un bellissimo viola per lato quindi
quasi tutto metallizzato con le varie
strega tour è molto bello molto
particolare anche in tema halloween
superò allungabile quella che bei colori
molto bene e adesso lui nei suoni mente
un po king è contento
che a suon i bellissimi fa piazza lo
schiacciano adesso sentiamo i rumori
delle di tutte le bolle questa volta
suoni momento ma come buone se un po più
in là
non ho detto che poco inglese ho fatto
capitan si posso credere imparata un
forfettone tipo di lime può essere
guardate che bel colore che raccomando
votate per me adesso vi lascerà il
sondaggio libero che che affermano la
cagnetta è anche col colore ci siamo
quasi metallizzato perlato e per lato
dobbiamo fare ragazzi chissà quando si
schiarisce come diventa in tasca proprio
qui ho da fare il suo rivale che bensì
milanesi perché metallizzato
allora mi lascio quale il sondaggio in
cui potete votare se ha vinto a vita
interesse o che ha vinto a cui i
gialloviola votate chi ha vinto e nei
commenti si fa primo così da uno schizzo
di vedere come va molto meglio di mio
wow
ok ora vi lasciamo qua quattro quelli su
cui cliccare cliccate qui per vedere il
video di halloween cliccate qui per
vedere il nord e non pensare di slide
piccate 4 vedere i nostri video quali
verdetti guidate qua per vedere i suoi
new york niente con la città pulite e
coraggio